alors le gouvernement du québec ne
participe pas encore à l'initiative de
tahoua j'en discute avec le ministre
responsable eric r ministre de la
transformation numérique et le
gouvernemental monsieur qu'est un bon
soir en somme ce moment juste avant de
terminer notre conversation pour que les
gens comprennent bien le mécanisme de
l'application supposons que moi je
reçois un test positif de la coved et
que j'ai l'application je recevrai un
code donc une clé que j'entrerai dans
l'application ça enverrait un message
aux jeunes rige été en contact dans les
deux dernières semaines pour au moins
quinze minutes et à moins de deux mètres
de distance leur disons donc que j'ai là
qu'ovide ou qu'ils ont été en contact
avec quelqu'un qui allait crever dès que
donc peut-être qu'ils devraient
eux-mêmes se fait artistique cela étant
dit monsieur caire notariaux participent
au programme - l'application rendant
accessible des données de la santé
publique
le québec ne le fait pas pourquoi mais
en fait nous ce qu'on a dit depuis le
début monsieur beauvais c'est que quelle
que soit l'utilité de l'application
quelles que soient les fonctionnalités
de l'application
il ya une condition qui doit absolument
être rencontrées pour qu'une application
puisse être puissent être efficaces et
c'est la participation des jeunes donc
ce que l'on m'a du québec ont souhaité
faire c'est consulter la population sur
l'appétit des québécois d'utiliser une
application comme celle là mais aussi de
bien cadrer le débat parce que vous
savez de toutes sortes d'applications et
on entend toutes sortes de choses donc
nous des parents nous voulu dire aux
québécois écoutent et oui ça pourrait
être un outil intéressant
voici ce que l'outil fait mais surtout
voici ce que l'outil ne fait pas donc
pas de géolocalisation parce que je vous
ai entendu monsieur beauvais eloi deux
mois du début corée parler d'une
application de traçage en est pas
question de traçage on parle d'une
application de notification de contact
et c'est très différent
justement parce qu'on ne fait pas de
traçage parce qu'on ne va pas pouvoir
suivre les gens la trace
on ne va pas utiliser les informations
biométriques
on ne fait aucun stockage de
renseignements personnels tour est
totalement anonyme et donc on voulait
placer le contexte est demandé aux
québécois dans ces circonstances est ce
que oui ou non vous pensez qu'un outil
comme celui là pour être utile et seriez
vous prêt à l'utiliser
d'accord traçage peut avoir plusieurs
significations moi je pense que
j'utilisais plus dans le sens de
retracer les contacts de gens qui ont
été en contact avec quelqu'un qui avait
la commune mais cela étant dit vous
parler de la participation et les
québécois sont ils prêts à participer à
adhérer à cette application dans le fond
ont dû mener une consultation en ligne
jusqu'à dimanche il y aura une
commission parlementaire à la mi-août
aussi mais vous fixé est ce que vous
vous allez fixer un pourcentage de
population qui est prêt à participer
avant de l'année d'aller de l'avant ou
de dire non à l'application mais il ya
déjà dédé des chiffres qui ont circulé
nous c'est le genre de question je pense
qu'ils pourraient très bien se reposer
en commission parlementaire encore loin
de moi l'idée de dire aux députés
pourquoi faire dans leurs commissions
parlementaires mais c'est certainement
des questions qu'on devra se poser les
traits qu'il n'a des ions forte c'est ça
vous dit même quand le ministre
responsable
absolument c'est la condition
sinequanone pour penser au reste
adhésion forte et les gens qui le
mettait à 60% pour que ça fonctionne est
ce que vous êtes à peu près à ce
niveau-là voter pour qui le jeu attendu
cinq ans le 6 80% des gens dont 56% de
l'afrique et de religion des téléphones
intelligents dont la population
on a quelque chose d'intéressant mais
encore là même quand on diminue le
pourcentage de participation
il ya quand même un corollaire qui se
fait avec la lacombe incapables de
contenir la propagation comme nous taire
bon je poursuis le gourmand du québec et
pas à l'étape de fixer le chiffre de
participation ont conçu les citoyens on
va consulter les espaces avec la
commission parlementaire en voilier on
va s'y intéresser on a aussi des
sondages d'opinion en interne pour
valider si toutes ces informations leur
sont carmen concorde et sont cohérents
et très rapidement on va en arriver à
une conclusion
et à ce moment là oui on se posera la
question à savoir quel est le type
d'application qui est disponible et qui
pourrait nous permettre de travailler
efficacement à lutter effectivement
considérer une éventuelle du greenback
vous comprenez que ça peut quand même
créé une certaine confusion dans
l'esprit des gens parce que ottawa et
pleins gaz dans l'application l'ontario
embarque dans le trait
d'ottawa puis là il ya des provinces
coop en fait le québec est la seule
province je pense à faire une
consultation de la population à ce sujet
là mais c'est comme si ce qui est bon
pour pitou devrait être bon pour minou
pourquoi c'est bon pour ottawa puis on
se questionne encore ici à québec
en fait la question c'est pourquoi on en
arrive à la conclusion que c'est bon
pour l'ontario moi je donne un exemple
l'alberta est allé de l'avant avec sa
propre application le taux de
participation n'a pas atteint les 20%
quelle est l'efficacité tout ça la
france est allée de l'avant avec une
application 2 pour cette participation
grand coup d'épée dans l'eau
à écouter les taux de participation le
plus élevé n'ont pas atteint les 20%
donc quelle est l'efficacité tout ça
alors est ce que on doit se lancer là
dedans sans que la population soit
complice de cette décision-là nouveau
gouvernement du québec et moi je me
dirais vous avez dit nous sommes les
seuls à consulter la population
moi j'en suis fier je suis fier du
gouvernement du québec qui de façon
responsable
là ce débat dans l'espace public dia la
population écoute et voici un outil kiwi
pourrait effectivement être utile nous
aider à lutter contre la propagation
communautaire est-ce que vous embarquer
mais encore une fois monsieur beauvais
c'est très important de bien situer le
débat parce que les gens ont des
craintes légitimes et ses craintes
légitimes là bas on y répond justement
10 à ce que l'application fait puisque
l'application de le faire parce qu'il y
ait un débat et un enjeu sanitaire on
veut combattre cette maladie pour lui
trouver tous les moyens technologiques
s'il le faut qu'on le faire ça c'est
dans un sens ni dans un autre principe
comprend que vous êtes d'accord mais sur
les modalités comment on fait là il ya
des questions est-ce que vous garantis
que si jamais le québec va de l'avant il
nie données personnelles seront protégés
qui aura pas de de transmission de
données personnelles
en fait monsieur beauvais je vais aller
plus loin que ça il n'y aura pas
d'utilisation des données personnelles
la façon dont ça fonctionne votre
application génère un numéro aléatoire
un identifiant aléatoire ou 30 secondes
et quand il ya contact avec une autre
application ce sont ces numéros l'homme
sont échangés quand vous êtes tester au
style la santé publique vous donne
encore une fois un identifiant l'idée
étant que vous devez consentir à
partager ses informations donc en 16,7
identifiants de ccum consentement que
vous donnez et en plus ça empêche les
gens qui voudraient faussement ceux
déclarés positifs
une fois que c'est fait les applications
téléchargent des fichiers et votre
application va rechercher dans le
fichier de ceux qui ont été déclarés
positifs si elle est identifiée qu'il a
générée est dans la liste sinon vous
n'avez pas été content en contact avec
quelqu'un testé positif
si oui vous avez été en contact et l'on
vous donne une série d'instructions mais
vous devez comprendre que tout cela
c'est un échange de numéros
d'identifiants générés aléatoirement qui
n'est relié à aucune information
personnelle et donc à ce moment là on
n'a pas à protéger les données
personnelles parce que nous ne répondons
pas de données personnelles et c'est
pour ça que je vous dis que c'est
important de faire ce débat là
cette consultation là parce que ça nous
permet d'expliquer aux gens ce que
l'application fait mais surtout ce
qu'elle ne fait pas et là on espère que
ce soit on a fait un bout de chemin dans
cette explication que vous avez
d'ailleurs très bien fait de façon à
l'accord de monsieur kermesse et
beaucoup dé bonne foi si je peux me
permettre le sublet consultation point
québec
oui c'est toujours vous